Jennifer is on the line in San Antonio
Jennifer your question for Chris and me
thank you Michael I'm trying to create
an emotion I know what I want to do and
what I don't want to do however my
question to you is financially I do not
face it better to file for child support
now or should I wait you're you're you
said you're pregnant yes okay in a few
months he doesn't want to be financially
so he has said he wanted to help out but
he hasn't so I've been painting
everything out of my pocket and it's
been very difficult I so that was my
question I don't know if I should after
the baby's born do I taking the chance
of or should I just wait until the baby
just hold it off well the baby is old
enough the day it's born and if not
before and so you'd have to check to see
what Texas law allows you prior to the
birth but I would suspect even at this
stage you know that there should be some
kind of an agreement
so obviously the man is the boy is not
you know being forthcoming and not
taking care of business and in a lot of
different ways right correct okay so I
guess you need to probably sit down with
an attorney and find out what the law
says in Texas where you live but my
suspicion is is that you're do support
already and you're already late and and
I don't know what your emotions are
telling you that would be different this
is not a financial or emotional decision
this is a taking care of your baby
decision and that needs money and he has
not if he's violent he doesn't that's
called a restraining order okay you
don't have to accept violence in order
to get child support payments in any
state
okay do you know that and so that's
that's wise
have visitation if he's an inappropriate
parent you just talked to DHS and you
get you know you get a restraining order
and so young boy needs to learn to grow
up and be a man and behave and not be
violent towards women or children and to
pay his bills for taking care of the
kids he creates and if he doesn't do
that on his own that's why we have a
court system to assist him in being a
man okay
no thank you okay you need to see an
attorney darling thank you I appreciate
that thank you bye-bye Chris I was just
reading some data on fatherhood and it's
just really amazing what the correlation
between having equality have father in
your life and success going forward and
you grew up without a dad yeah you know
I grew up with three violent fathers so
they kind of came and went and not to
mention all the violent boyfriends that
came over but I feel very lucky but the
reason why I feel so fortunate and
blessed is I had a lot of father figures
come into my life and speak into my life
but you know in this scenario it's
really sad to hear Jennifer's
predicament and my prayer is that that
there's some men around her maybe it's
our brother or maybe it's an uncle or
maybe it's some kind of family member
they can come in and and be that support
that male support for that that unborn
child but in terms of emotional yeah
yeah there needs to be a man around that
you can count on it's just they parents
in two different ways and they handle
they they provide emotional stability in
two different ways you know Meg maker
was talking about that at smart
conferences last weekend and that's why
they came to mind and and so you have to
get that extra person in there and then
also you know where somebody thinks
they're gonna be a tough guy with a lady
that you know a guy being around
suddenly changes that scenario doesn't
it yeah and most of the time my prayer
for that situation is that he's going
through a phase or he's going through
some issue but the research shows that
if he's like that now at this age he's
probably just that kind of guy but I'm
with my prayers that I just he just you
know gets his act together and he can
I've just seen a lot of men out there we
of course you and I talked to a lot of
people they can turn it around they can
come back to say you're sorry and
back on the right track but that that
unborn child needs a father figure and
that's the and the care for that child
is the number one thing in this whole
discussion yeah
and and the courts will make sure he
does that yeah the biggest thing with
Jennifer she just needs educators she
didn't know what her options are yeah
she feels in and she's intimidated yeah
very yeah the fact that she's even like
a reluctant about fighting for this baby
I mean she needs to be used to get some
that intensity that we talked about in
previous calls she used to get that
about our unborn child and I think she's
a little bit scared yeah which which is
totally understandable
you